Six years ago, I got an invitation
to go around a bobsleigh track,
and I was too scared
and I turned it down.
But since then, these folks have
been helping run this channel,
and they got me over my
fear of roller coasters.
So thank you for that.
This is Chris Spring,
world-class bobsleigh athlete,
and this is the Whistler
Sliding Centre in Canada.
So for the season finale,
for the Christmas special,
we brought the entire team
out here to Canada,
and we're gonna throw ourselves
down a bobsleigh track.
Wait, what?
(group laughing)
Oh, don't pretend
you don't know!
Which includes, by the
way, the camera team.
♪ (dramatic bluesy rock music)
Hello.
How's it going?
Going well. Tom.
Welcome to the Sliding Centre.
My name is Philippe.
I'm gonna be showing you
a few things before we go.
So follow me and
we can get started.
Right.
You're gonna go down the
fastest, steepest track in the world.
So on average, speed for
track is 135km an hour.
Here, top speed is
155 from the top.
So big jump.
We need to regroom
the track by hand,
believe it or not,
because of the speed.
So that's what
the guys are doing.
So, a little warning
about the ride.
You might not like it.
And there's nothing we
can do about it, okay?
Yeah, once you start, that's it.
You're in it for the ride.
It's nothing like you expect.
You're gonna pull
three to four G-forces,
so you're gonna weigh three
to four times your weight.
Those are positive Gs,
means it's pressure on you.
There's no negative Gs.
The negative Gs,
that's what you experience
in a roller coaster.
When the stomach goes up,
drop, upside down.
We don't have that.
It's not scary.
The athletes, when they
start from the top,
they go up to 155 km,
five to six Gs on their back.
That's why they only go
for three runs a day
or two, never more.
After three, they really
can't take it anymore.
So it's three minutes or two
minutes of training per day.
Wow.
Because after that,
you feel really tired,
and you can't take it anymore.
So if you have any
heart condition,
any hand, neck, back injury,
pregnant, osteoporosis,
please don't go.
We're really serious about that.
Yeah.
Okay?
We have one crew
member who has a...
will not be going
for medical reasons.
So that's...
(crew laughing)
Okay, I didn't know if
you wanted to mention
that on camera or not!
I was just gonna say
"medical reasons."
That's fine.
So when there's a cut,
like the one on a
competition sled,
the nose can move.
The nose is articulated.
And when the nose
can move like that,
the sled can go higher
in the corner,
and the back falls, and
they can get more speed.
The downside is they can
go too high and they crash.
So they're easy to crash.
The other one is
called a plank sled.
There's no cut.
They're slower,
smoother, safer,
but because they're slower,
we don't use them with the public.
We're gonna use a real one.
Oh wow, okay.
So we're going in the
less safe one?
Yes.
Okay.
We're going with the faster one.
I wouldn't call it less safe.
I call them the more fun one.
(others laughing)
Alright?
We're gonna start you from
corner seven, not the top.
There's different reasons for that.
So the top is... it's hell.
The one reason we don't start from
the top is because of this corner.
You see that fake straight line?
This is the hardest corner
in the world by far.
The athlete during the 2010
Olympics named it 50-50.
We thought that was a
funny name, so we kept it.
50-50 what?
50% chance to go through it
properly on your runners.
Oh, wow.
Or 50% chance of...
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, cool.
Let's not go
full-speed through that.
So this is what could happen.
If you're in a crash,
the sled's gonna slide
on its side or upside down
all the way to the bottom.
We have staff waiting with
some hooks at the bottom
in case of a crash.
And then the staff's
gonna stop you.
It's gonna help you to exit
the sled and the track,
and you're gonna have a
good story for tonight.
Okay.
Does it happen often?
Uhh... no.
I do not believe you, okay?
Alright.
That's it, ready to go?
Ready.
Alright.    Ready.
Let's drive to the top.
♪ (uplifting holiday music)
Ready for some bobsledding?
Yeah. We are sled number one.
Sled number two is
behind the various cameras
here at the minute,
so, yeah.
My nerves haven't kicked in yet.
Have they for you?
Long ago.
Okay.
Yeah, they did.
They've dissipated a bit,
but they'll come back.
I'm waiting.
Honestly didn't realise it
didn't have a back for realsies.
Yeah, no back door.
Until this morning.
There's a little bit of a lip.
You'll be fine.
Just hold on.
Yeah, you'll be
surprised how much
the pressure will
squish you into place.
Okay.
And not allow you
to fall out the back.
So how long have
you been doing this?
This is my 16th year
as a bobsledder.
Wow.
We did the research.
You're most decorated
Olympian bobsledder,
most decorated Canadian
Olympian in the house?
Well, I don't know about that,
but I've definitely been to
four Olympic games, which is...
one less than one other
Olympic bobsledder.
Yeah.
But we couldn't get him
to come here today.
So you have me.
We're both—
I'm trying to be not too awkward,
and you're trying to be
nice and Canadian.
You're self-deprecating
here and, alright.
We're in good hands then.
You are in good hands, yeah.
This is... a heck of a run.
I'm just looking at that and going,
that doesn't look that steep.
It's a long way down, but...
Am I sorta doing pride
before a fall here?
'Cause I did—
You're nodding.
I've seen the track, mate.
Okay, this is the thing.
They've seen it, they've
recce'd and I haven't.
This is all I've seen.
Right here it
doesn't look too steep,
but once we get going...
By corner 11, 12, 13,
it really starts picking up,
and you'll start to
feel that pressure
that I was talking about.
How long's the run gonna be?
Around 40 seconds.
Sounds quick, but...
It does!
I'll let you know
when we get down.
How are you feeling about it?
Yeah, I feel like the first
few corners are gonna be okay,
and we'll probably
get cocky, and then...
our heads will start doing this.
Yeah, especially if you don't
know which way the corners go.
I'm not sure how much you
studied the track or not.
We did not.
(laughs)
In hindsight, that would've
been a really good idea.
Your instinct will kick in
when things do start,
you know, rattling around
quite a bit and you'll end up...
Yeah.
kinda resorting to that
turtle type shape that you'll make.
How much steering
is involved in it?
'Cause we got told basically:
Skeleton, goes down on
its own more or less.
Luge, really, really difficult.
Bobsleigh, you have to
know your line.
You have to come through.
It's not like...
It's not like if you didn't steer,
it would just go slower.
If you didn't steer, it would...
Exactly yeah.
We would be on our heads.
Right.
And how much of
"on our heads"
is there actually when we...?
'Cause I saw these little
guardy things up here.
Yeah, they put these in
for the public ride here.
Yeah.
We have these extra little humps.
It's mainly just the visual to make
you feel that you are more safe.
Right, yeah.
That's really what
I wanted to know.
Yeah, you'll be on—
That's great. Thanks mate.
You'll be on
your head for sure,
if we are on our heads.
How are the folks
behind the cameras feeling?
Are y'all okay?
Great, just...
Great.
I didn't have to go,
so I'm fine.
So Kirsten just enjoying
the show, right?
Jamie, how are you feeling?
Fine.
That was a lie.
Maybe?
Maybe I'm exuding
this confidence.
Yeah.
So we're gonna walk
down into corner seven.
This is the first curve that
we're gonna be entering today,
and we'll talk a little bit
about the science
and the physics behind
what we're trying to do,
how we're manipulating
the sled in curve seven.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go.
What's unique about this curve
is that it is laid back
quite a lot more
than most corners in the world.
So when you say laid
back, like the angle...
Yeah.
that the wall's at?
Let's come up a
little bit closer here,
and see if we can see.
The track is kind of...
We call it an open curve.
So there isn't much of
an overhang of the roof.
It's not cupped like this.
And when it's open like this,
the pressure is...
a lot more difficult
to feel in your hands.
Because the sled—
We always talk about
if we did nothing,
what would happen to the sled?
And then we're trying to
manipulate the sled to be on
the perfect line from there.
How do you learn that feeling?
Like how—
'Cause you can't go
down at half speed.
That doesn't make sense.
True.
So how do you...
The first time you
take the controls...
how do you know what to do?
Yeah, it's very difficult to teach.
And we give new drivers,
we give them all this
information and we hope that...
Okay!
They understand what
we're talking about.
Alright.
So it's instinctive,
is it, a lot of it is?
It is, yeah.
And a lot of it is that
feeling that I talk about.
We feel about the pressure,
I feel it in in my stomach,
I feel it in my butt in
the amount of pressure
that's in my body.
And so I kind of steer
using that feeling as well.
Alright, should we do it?
Yeah, let's do it.
♪ (throbbing synth riff)
♪ (slow, heavy techno music)
(music ends)
So I'm in first.
You're going to stand here for a sec.
Yep.
Go on the other side.
I need to check what you're going
to be doing.
Okay.
Go inside.
Yep.
Come on in.
Come in closer.
Have a seat.
Have a seat?
Yeah.
Okay.
Now you're nervous?
Here?
I should have done
this six years ago.
And then you... (inaudible)
Okay.
Cool.
How are you feeling back there?
Do you wanna go?
So we are ready?
Feels very exposed, doesn't it?
Tom, when I get in, my bum
is really close to your face.
My apologies.
Alright.
There's nothing we
can do about that.
Just keep these to
the outside. There we go.
Alright!
Cosy?
Yeah.
It's comfortable, isn't it?
Yeah, I'm happy with this.
I'm worried about like
keeping my back straight.
I'm not sure what
counts as leaning back.
Okay, that's leaning back,
'cause I just hit Guy in the head.
Hey buddy.
Sorry about that.
(nervous chuckling)
It's quite comfortable, isn't it?
I don't have anything
to lean against.
The track is in use by
Chris, Tom, Cambria, and Guy.
You guys ready?
Let's do it.
Let's do it, here we go!
Good luck.
See you at the bottom.
Three, two, one.
(ringing cowbells)
Come on, let's have it!
Let's go, boys!
Come on!
(others cheering)
Right. Make yourself big.
Here we go.
Corner seven.
Let's go!
(inaudible shout)
Woo-hoo!
Woo!
Woo-ho-ho-hoo!
How're you doing back there?
Way to go, gang!
Welcome back to Earth everyone.
Woo!
(relieved laughter)
Little bit of grayout
on that last corner.
How are you doing back there?
Yeah, fine. Survived it.
I loved it.
We made it!
I can't feel my fingers.
That's interesting.
Woo!
Oh my god... (inaudible)
That was brilliant.
I loved it.
Come on!
Ohh!
Alright.
How are you feeling Cambria?
Oh my god,
that was incredible.
That was so good.
Oh my god.
How we doing gang?
Thank you Chris.
Guy, we survived!
Thank you so much.
Didn't fall out the back.
Nothing happened.
Right?
You happy?
Yeah.
Very happy.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Yeah, my pleasure.
This is what I love,
right here.
Seeing the smiles.
This is great.
Alright, camera crew.
It's your turn.
Yeah.
Up you go, guys.
How you doing?
How you feeling?
Good to go.
A man of few words.
♪ (upbeat techno-rock riff)
♪ (upbeat rock music)
(music ends)
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]